le sport et vous les verrez peut-être un
jour sur le Tour de France les 160
coureurs du Tour de l'Avenir était dans
l'Indre aujourd'hui pour l'épreuve du
contre-la-montre autre étape importante
salière entre noisettes et Chinon 195 km
au total
âgé de moins de 23 ans ses espoirs sont
déjà d'excellents coureurs pour le plus
grand plaisir du public ambiance avec
les la Turquie
encouragement crier applaudissements une
vraie haie d'honneur pour les coureurs
du Tour de l'Avenir l'arrivée de la
deuxième étape à Chinon a su intéresser
de nombreux curieux venus pour certains
d'outre-manches
on est venu en vélo ce matin et on a
voulu voir comment se débrouiller les
coureurs ils sont sûrement un peu plus
rapides que nous d'ailleurs
beau soleil on a la retraite on profite
un petit peu quoi pour faire voir aux
enfants une course de vélo comment ça se
passe
j'y connais pas grand chose mais j'aime
bien le vélo
une 59e édition qui rassemble aussi les
passionnés venus pour suivre de près la
compétition le Tour de l'Avenir c'est
quand même le petit tour de France
je pense que c'est jeune coureurs qui
ont des chances de d'être un jour sur le
Tour de France et peut-être même le
rapporter le Tour de l'Avenir mais en
lumière les espoirs du cyclisme de moins
de 23 ans ce lundi se déroulait l'étape
la plus longue du Tour 95 km passive
évident pour l'actuel 4e au classement
général de la course c'était long
c'était long et ça a pas rouler très
vite donc c'était encore plus long et
puis s'il faisait très chaud et
apparemment c'était très nerveux parce
que bah la course a pas été très usante
bah c'est la plus belle course des moins
de 23 ans donc c'est sûr ça fait plaisir
et bah c'est de l'expérience pour la
suite la course continue pour une
arrivée finale le 27 août au cœur des
Alpes pas de répit pour le cyclisme car
dans la foulée commence la toute
première édition du Tour de l'Avenir
féminin
[Applaudissements]